normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government I
chose the best source I could out.com
and they've titled it this trailer for a
quote comedy film about trans athletes
is the worst thing we've ever
seen Jeremy what do you have to say for
yourself well I'm looking up the article
now so it says um I I chose this one
because of course we have to go for the
criticism it's a well-known fact that
right-wingers not make good art and
don't have a sense of humor at the same
time I just want to pause uh y'all call
Joe Rogan right-wing and he is one of
the top comedians of all time so nice
try but let's read they say the daily
wire is reminding us all with the new
preview for its first feature length
company comedy lady ballers in a world
where women's sports is being
transformed the daily wire calls fowl
with the most triggering comedy of the
year so of course uh they're they're
absolutely triggered by it but in real
news we have this story from uh daily
wire so you just went on Patrick B
David's show and the headline is Jeremy
boring says theaters won't touch lady
Ballers because Hollywood has made
transgenderism its religion but uh the
just just to get the whole thing going
you put out a new trailer it's about
guys who find a path towards making
money by identifying as women but why
don't why don't you take it away yeah I
mean it's all in the name right lady
Ballers uh here here I'm want to read
this from out though because it it sets
it up well it says the premise of Lady
Ballers seems to be that any outof shape
50-year-old white man is by nature of
being a man a better athlete than any
woman could ever hope to be you see
women are just factually bad at sports
this movie States first of all what
nobody involved in the movie is uh 50
second of all we do not state that women
are factually bad at sports we state
that women are factually worse at sports
than men it's science it is it is TR it
is truly science don't you trust the
science men sometimes men are stronger
and faster than women and this is why
full stop the left can't they can't even
acknowledge that basic fundamental
reality since they can't acknowledge
that basic fundamental reality they
can't understand why we have any of the
opinions that we have they're not
allowed to know that it's true and so
they don't know that it's true but then
I would I would ask why then do they
have testosterone limits why do they
have that standard for so the reality is
because they do know they're just lying
that's right well and we see it across
the country we see in Maine and in
California just recently there were male
athletes competing in women's um you
know Cross Country Events and they were
taking home all the awards for sure and
that's going to keep happening the
average high school boy involved in
track runs faster than world record
Olympian women wow yeah we saw the
women's US soccer team was beaten by a
like high school team yeah when I was
talking about this article that said
Prehistoric Women were better hunters
and it the argument was that because of
and it's it's it's all nonsense It's
like because because of um women have
have they carry more body fat they have
more energy for endurance that that
actually creates drag and more weight
and so I was like I can debunk this very
simply I think actually your debunking
was better they were pregnant they were
nursing children so they're not out
hunting but there I just said okay I
pulled up marathon time and distance and
sure men beat women in all of it well
let me just here's a little uh mental
exercise for you a riddle if you will
why do we even have women's sports
because sometimes people wear
dresses answered a riddle with a riddle
we have women's sports because if you
didn't have women's sports women would
never win at any sports the whole
purpose of creating women's sports a as
a category was so that there was a place
where women could Excel well and that's
what Title 9 was all about right and now
that's been completely destroyed and the
left left wing the leftist argument is
we have women's sports because sometimes
people wear dresses you know but that's
seriously it and and that's looks like
the premise of your movie where these
guys are like wait I can identify as a
woman playing the team and then identify
as a man later yep gender fluid the
story is actually based sometimes you
wear a dress sometimes you don't jman's
movie is based on zubie the yeah exactly
well there was a thing recently there
was a a a a
trans um identified male murdered a
trans identified female in Norway just
gave me a headache I know it really
happens but the Norwegian the Norwegian
um papers reported this as woman kills
man but really it's just your typical
man kills woman just like we see all
over the place this is why I can't stand
I think I'm not sure Fox News does this
I think they may use preferred pronouns
or or presumed pronouns I think is the
important distinction presumed pronouns
are when these media organizations will
use atypical pronouns without actually
knowing preferred pronouns so for
instance uh The Daily Mail does this all
the time if there is a person that that
is presumed to be trans they will use
the inverse pronouns even though they
don't actually know if that person uses
the pronouns they're trying to because
of like UK hate speech laws or something
like when I was still a professor
teaching journalism fiction all that
stuff the style guide changed and they
wanted black to be capitalized but white
to be lowercase so there's these little
Insidious ways that they're putting
they're changing literal language I
refuse to do that oh I'll never do that
it's ridiculous it's really stupid it's
insane yeah it's bad enough that we have
to capitalize Hispanic which means
person from South America who speaks
Spanish doesn't I don't even know if it
means from South America does it well it
doesn't mean Spain it no it means speak
Spanish doesn't it I thought it meant I
thought it just meant Cal America but
not then I guess Brazil is out of that
huh Brazil is not in that and that's
what sort of shows the whole lie right
there that makes it just absurd w y
here's a line from this out article
about us it says I love how much you
love this
article here's the thing if you're going
to win an election if if if like you're
way up in the polls you always watch
MSNBC right it's much it's much more fun
to read what they say about us than what
we say about it but I like this it's not
clear if director and star Jeremy boring
has ever written or acted before I mean
it is clear if you could Google in the
time you did this or if he has ever met
a woman in real life and the answer is I
guess I don't know based on whatever
descriptor they might use for the how
how do they Define it how do they Define
it holy moly I love it this is fun you
should frame this so so I just looked it
up and uh Hispanic is a Spanish-speaking
person living in the US living in the US
comma especially one of Latin American
descent so you're you're you're correct
but I'm close the the general concept is
if you if you like Jeremy if you learn
Spanish right now you're Hispanic yeah
that's weird I don't quite understand
but uh I guess realistically uh you know
there's also a joke in the trailer about
um trans age yeah where but this is
trans age was attempted in a lawsuit um
I think it was a professor who did it as
a an attack on the concept of identity
it may may have been in Europe as well
saying I actually identify as 30 when
they're 59 or something and the cour
there's that British guy who wears
diapers and says he identifies as step
fonnie like a 5-year-old girl or
something is he the guy who films
himself in public I don't know but he
was adopted by um other grown-ups who
let him play with their
daughter which is
nasty absolutely not I'd love to see you
Shane second listen in New York New York
City gender identity is a protected
category which includes gender
expression and gender expression is
legally defined as self-expression
so I I I I went over this in 2018 quite
literally you the clothing you wear the
name you use you cannot be discriminated
against so that this this means
everything you could you could show up
in stilts and clown makeup and they
can't tell you're not allowed to wear it
it's it's it's against my gender
identity I wear these clothes it would
be discriminatory now New York is saying
I don't know if you saw this weight and
height you can't discriminate on the
basis of weight mhm no discrimination
against fat people so but can't fit so
think about this someone goes to a movie
theater New York and there's 300b and
they say I can't fit in these chairs
well now you're discriminating because
you're not providing an accommodation to
large people didn't the firemen in New
York change the weight requirements
years back too yeah and cops all kinds
of maybe not just in New York but I was
in New York at the time when I saw it
it's uh yeah it's it's insane yeah I
don't get it but here's the thing we
have to mock these ideas I agree what
what brought us to make lady Ballers is
one understanding the power of mockery
and and two honestly something that Joe
Rogan said about a year ago a little
over a year ago he had he had a guest on
his show and he said you know nobody he
talks about this a lot no Hollywood
won't make comedies anymore and it's
absolutely true Barack Obama destroyed
rock and roll and he destroyed comedy
and he destroyed America other than
those three things great
president he also killed American
citizens without charge of trial let's
uh nice but he he made it impossible for
us to tell jokes yeah and that's why
from the '90s and the early 2000s you
had great comedies being produced by
Hollywood you haven't had one since
Tropic Thunder because you're not
allowed to make any jokes so yeah what
is the go are there any recent comedies
I mean but they're not funny you can't
make a comedy no really and so I wanted
to use comedy in and moery Rogan talks
about it all the time and he said to a
guest a little over a year ago he said
nobody can make a comedy now he said if
if anybody was going to do it it' have
to be one of these conservative
streamers like the daily wire and when
he said it yes people send you that what
Joe Rogan mentioned the daily wire you
know they send it to you but it really
struck me and I thought this this is
kind of a a challenge and a
responsibility if it is true that only
the daily wire could do this then it
stands to reason that the daily wire
must do it if we actually believe the
things that we purport to believe and we
actually are uniquely capable of
challenging this new status quo wherein
you're not allowed to make fun of
anything including the most absurd
things that are happening in our culture
y then we just have to do it just just
anything I mean uh uh over the holiday
weekend I'm I'm hanging out with Sheamus
and my girlfriend and it's after
Thanksgiving so you know Sheamus is from
Chicago as well and we were we were all
making jokes about our backgrounds the
the the the the issue of family family
history comes up and then we make joke
Sheamus started Sheamus makes jokes
about being Irish and being the Potato
Man and stuff and we play along with it
and he laughs and then we make jokes
about Korea and we're all laughing at
each other and the left would call them
racist jokes I would just call it me and
my friends having a good time with each
other and laughing well I'll tell you
this in the '90s we we could still make
those jokes they were good jokes they
were good jokes and there was far far
less racial division in the country I
remember yeah that was very distinct and
come coming up into the 2000s and you're
looking back at the 90s going we were
colorblind we were friends with
everybody none of it was a very big deal
and I remember um distinctly probably
something like 2012 running into an old
friend of mine from college a black
woman we were hanging out at this bar in
Brooklyn and we were just chatting and
she said something that was totally
different than what she thought when we
were in college she said that when
people see her she wants them to see her
Blackness first she wants them to see
her race first and I was like but but
why like that's not what I see when I
look at you and the switch was that now
it was racist to not notice race yeah
that's right yes whereas previously none
of us had cared at all cult
indoctrination from similar backgrounds
you know similar schools all of that we
went to the same you know private
college everything watching watching
them destroy comedy though with their
ideology was so hurtful for me because
comedy is one of my favorite art forms
you know for two reasons it brings
people together we can make fun of each
other I love kill Tony it's one of my
favorite shows they roast the heck out
of each other they're brutal I love that
I do that with my friends but also like
Mel Brooks used to say comedy mocking
people could destroy your enemies right
and that's what he would do in his look
at Rickles like suddenly you're friends
with everybody exactly but let's let's
let's uh actually I'd like to ask you
directly about the film and what can you
say about it I mean I don't I don't know
if you want to reveal the plot or break
down the the general premise what's
going on yeah I'll say more about it
than is is present in the trailer which
is that of
course we start our journey by trying to
become successful by trying to get back
in the game where where this you know
I'm a coach and I get together my former
State winning boys basketball team and
say hey if we call ourselves women we
can get back into the game pretty soon
we realize we're being driven to this by
my new girlfriend who is a a journalist
and and she has very ulterior motives
you know but she she's excited for it
well she's driving it she's like here's
what we're going to do think of the
sponsorships think of the fame she and
she gets the exclusive and and I'm
learning I'm I'm I'm hearing all these
ideas about the trans movement from my
eight-year-old daughter because she goes
to public school and then I pick her up
from school every day and she tells me
things like gender fluidity and
pansexuality and all this stuff and she
educates you she educates me yeah as
they do as you do y but pretty soon we
we realized that it's not just
basketball I my guys could literally win
at every sport I mean there's a really
funny line where where I'm like hey to
one of the guys like hey you want to
hang out later and he's like nah I got
to learn how to do a backhand so I can
qualify for the women's Olympic
tenness although In fairness we don't
use the term Olympic because you may not
know this you do not have free speech in
this country where the word Olympic is
concerned really is that's why I say
Global games yeah it's the global games
you cannot use the term Olympics by law
in this country an actual statute the
United States legal uh legal codee
why some I'm running for yeah you got to
run for we executive order wow when did
you realize that in the process though
like when you ref very late very late in
the process yeah unfortunately and
anyway all of this to say and this
brings it full circle what to what got
me on the topic of promoting my own
beautiful movie is that toward the end
of the movie I have to make a case for
why even though men are better at
virtually everything now that's a joke
but everything in this case is sports
you why would someone who is a female
want to continue being a female would
they not aspire to be a man and it was
challenging to come up with a list of
things to say in a serious moment of the
film that women are good at that people
wouldn't roll their eyes at and then I
because the things that women are good
at are things that our culture has
decided don't have high value thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net